Frank,
welcome to the show.
It's great to be here.
Thank you.
I am so thrilled to have you here to help me solve the riddles of life.
And I thought I would start with maybe some,
some common ground and it relates to a book called built to scratch so that the
background personally speaking is that built a scratch along with a few other
books,
have traveled with me for more than 30 years now.
So they helped set me on my first entrepreneurial journey step and have traveled
from house to house,
apartment to apartment,
country to country ever since.
And in the course of doing research,
I had read that when you became the CEO of Home Depot,
that you had read passages from built a scratch.
Right.
And I was curious if you recalled any of that,
why you chose to do that.
If you could walk us through it,
that would be fantastic.
First,
your research is great.
Absolutely right.
Uh,
that's very exciting that the book is important to you.
Go here.
It's hugely important to me.
First,
the book is,
uh,
the story of Home Depot.
It was written by Bernie Marcus and Arthur blank and about Bernie and Arthur and
Ken Lang gone and they're finding of home depot.
It's one of the great entrepreneurial stories of our century,
of our times because Bernie and Arthur had been fired from their prior job,
can lank own,
said to them when they got five,
you just got hit by a golden horseshoe in the ass.
You're so lucky.
And then they went and established the home depot,
which was,
uh,
the most successful retail concept of its time,
fastest to 10 billion,
20 billion,
30 billion,
40 billion.
Uh,
my connection with the book is,
is it's very meaningful to me,
not only because it's the story of the founding of the home depot,
but also because of my start as the CEO of Home Depot.
Uh,
I did not have a background that would lead anyone to think that I'd ever be the
CEO of the Home Depot.
In fact,
when the board called me and said,
we want you to be the CEO,
I said,
you ought to take a day and think about this because I have,
while I had been at home depot for a few years,
I had not been really doing a lot of the retail work.
I've been doing m and a activity in real estate and that kind of thing and I
said,
you ought to spend a day think about it and think about hiring a real retailer
and I need to think about it.
Obviously they called back at the end of the day,
they still offered me the job and I obviously took the job,
but I can honestly say that a nanosecond before the call,
I was not thinking I'm going to be the CEO of this company.
There were no moments of driving along and the darker night thinking,
oh,
what would I do if I were running this place?
I was completely unprepared.
And then like a lot of retailers,
you know,
we have a way of communicating to our associates at the time,
home depot at around 350,000 associates,
we have little,
uh,
TV that we beam in messages to the break rooms and I have to go and address the
350,000 associates.
Um,
being singularly unprepared at the time.
My,
my son,
uh,
Home Depot as a program of returning veterans,
giving them jobs in the store.
My son was an attorney returning Iraq veteran,
rocky board veteran had come back.
He'd been an assistant store manager,
was now a store manager at home depot.
And so I gave him a call and I said,
frank,
he's the same name as I.
Uh,
I said,
frank,
do you have any thoughts on what I should say?
And first she said,
wow,
good luck.
And then the second,
the second thing he said was,
I don't know what you should say,
but I can tell you how I start every store meeting in my store.
I said,
great,
what do you do?
And he said,
I take bill from scratch and I read from it,
I'll read a passage from it.
I go,
this is brilliant.
And so I pick up the book,
I flipped madly through it to find something that's I think is relevant.
And in the book they talk about the inverted pyramid and the leadership concept
where the CEO is at the bottom and the customers and the front line associates
are at the top.
And so I use that a reading from built from scratch.
And then inverted pyramid is my first communication to our associates.
And then for the next eight years as CEO,
uh,
I spent time figuring out what does that actually mean?
Uh,
how do you lead from an inverted pyramid,
um,
perspective and what are the leadership lessons that you pull from that?
So yes,
a hugely important book.
It's a great book.
Uh,
unfortunately it's out of print,
but I'm sure I could get it for anybody who wants it.
Yeah.
Maybe we could get the publisher to do it.
Yeah,
that would be great.
That would be great.
Give them a heads up when this is going to land,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
So I'd like to start right in the middle of the action kind of in media rests
with something like that.
And then rewind the clock.
So if we go back to your childhood,
could you tell us a bit about where you grew up and how you would describe your
childhood?
Uh,
I grew up in right outside of Boston,
Massachusetts,
a family of five.
Uh,
I was the fourth of five.
unfortunately my three older siblings have died.
My mom though just had her 100th birthday and still lives in the house I grew up
in,
uh,
had a great,
very family oriented experience growing up.
Very close family and we have a lot of relatives in the area.
So New England sort of home still.
What did your mom do for a hundredth birthday?
Uh,
so we had a big party and we had lots of relatives,
lots of her friends.
Uh,
she,
um,
she's the kind of person who,
if you say,
uh,
mention any name,
she will know exactly what that person's father did,
what their sister did.
She'll have a backstory that will go on for 15 or 20 minutes.
Uh,
she works the phone constantly.
She did that growing up and she's done that even to the age of a hundred.
She's sharp as a tack weld what recall very well and very storytelling.
So you just,
you go,
wow.
I had no idea that there was that much interesting going on in their life.
You know,
they had a twin sister and the twin sister ran away with the grocery man and you
know,
it was just all that kind of detail.
Fascinating stuff.
What did you think you were going to grow up to be when you were in,
say,
high school or when you were younger?
I,
I was interested in politics,
so,
um,
I worked on campaigns.
Uh,
when I got out of college,
I worked in the state legislature in Massachusetts.
Uh,
after I went to law school,
I then ended up in Washington DC.
I had a very traditional,
uh,
Washington DC lawyer,
government career move back and forth,
uh,
from private practice and into the government.
So the I politics fascinate me.
I was interested in politics.
Fascinating.
What,
what led to that?
Uh,
or what about it?
I think you start,
you start by by,
uh,
the issues are so interesting.
Uh,
you think you can impact people's lives.
Um,
there,
uh,
it,
you know,
power is a fascinating thing and yeah,
so politics is a source of power and it's fascinating because of it.
Did you experience conversations about politics over the dinner table or how
were you introduced to it?
Not a bit,
no,
not a bit.
Uh,
it was entirely,
um,
I self generated,
I don't know where it came from,
but it,
yeah,
no one else in my family was remotely interested in politics.
That was my thing
is,
so as I was mentioning before we started recording,
I've had a hell of a time trying to figure out what path to take with this
conversation because you have such an eclectic background and people will have
heard certainly a fair amount of this in the introduction.
But I'll just mention a few things and then I'll get to the question.
So you have law clerk for Supreme Court justice,
General Counsel for Ge.
I'm skipping a lot.
Deputy Secretary.
Now,
why do you say deputy secretary of the Department of energy or is it better to
just say deputy secretary of energy,
Department of Energy and then CEO of Home Depot and then certainly at least as
one of our mutual friends has put it,
you are the least retired,
retired person.
He knows
I have a lot of friends who are lawyers look into her lawyers.
Yeah.
A former lawyers and they tend to be very uh,
certainty focused and uh,
averse to entrepreneurship.
So how have you,
and if this is even accurate,
ended up with this combination of very strong legal background and ability to
manage in amidst uncertainty and combine those two.
It's really unusual from my experience at least.
Uh,
I'm probably an awful lot accidental.
so the first part accidental was a group of us set up our own law firm.
So there are 12 of us who set up our own law firm and that was kind of my first
experience with entrepreneurial activity.
I could say I was singularly bad.
I feel affirmed it great.
Uh,
most of my instincts about how to do it actually looking back are pretty funny
cause I was wrong.
Uh,
so that was an introduction to entrepreneurial activity.
I left Washington,
uh,
to go to Ge to be the general counsel of a business in Schenectady,
New York.
And everybody thought that's the stupidest thing we've ever heard.
Why would you leave Washington and a great legal practice and go to Schenectady?
And mostly it was,
by that time I was kind of sick of politics and sick of Washington and,
uh,
I was the beneficiary of the way Ge did HR.
So the basically they move people around every 18 months,
but they never bothered to move the lawyers because who,
you know,
they're not going to bother to move the lawyers.
So after about five or six years,
I'm the person around the table who sort of knows how the business works.
And I've listened to this and I've observed over time and,
uh,
they offered me a job going onto the business side and then the rest of it,
um,
being a lawyer is great.
Uh,
having been a lawyer is even better.
So I really,
I really enjoyed the business side and found it much,
much more fascinating than the legal side.
Uh,
how did you make the decision,
walk us through making the decision to leave the law practice and take the job
at GE because that's a skill or it could be a scary step.
And I know certainly looking around myself at my friends who have what most
people would consider a successful legal careers,
uh,
they often pine after these types of changes,
but very few of them actually take the leap.
So how did you,
uh,
how did you make that decision?
I,
there were two things.
The first,
the first just as a scene setter is it is the case.
I have never made as a salary,
more money than I made as a lawyer.
So I did more with my draw from the law firm than through to being CEO of the
Home Depot.
So it was,
it was a very good legal practice.
The problem with legal practice after a while that you realize is,
um,
there's such a disincentive for any kind of efficiency,
right?
Somebody comes in with a problem and you go,
I know this prominent,
I can name this tune in three notes.
Well,
no,
actually that's not what you,
that's not the business model.
You want to say,
Oh boy,
that's a complex symphony.
That's going to be 3000 notes.
And so the idea of trying to do something that's cumulative rather than a
billing your time by the hours,
really what appealed to me.
And so,
and,
and Washington's a very,
um,
Washington's very close little culture and I want to just get out of,
out of that closed culture and it's connected in New York,
sounded like the far end of the earth.
Now at the time,
were you single married when you're married,
married?
How did that,
uh,
how did you deliver the news or how did you discuss the possibility of that
switch?
I,
you know,
after you're comfortable saying I don't,
I don't,
I don't know that we had a lot of discussion around it,
but it was clear that I was not,
I just was becoming increasingly unhappy,
uh,
on the legal side.
And while I'm not sure everybody was thrilled.
I knew my family was thrilled to be moving to a it,
you know,
we lived in Albany,
but to be moving to upstate New York,
they wrote him with,
it gets chilly.
I grew up in New York,
but on long island upstate gets chilly for people who haven't been there.
Upstate is Chile and um,
yeah,
it's very chilly.
Uh,
Ge,
uh,
Ge is another company in addition to Home Depot,
even though I've never done anything myself in any industries related to either.
That is fascinating.
Yes.
Uh,
when did you first meet Jack Welch?
Oh,
early,
early on.
Um,
and,
and then I ended up as a direct report for Jack.
Uh,
I,
Jack Welch's.
I mean the founders of Home Depot,
uh,
Bernie Marcus,
Ken Lang,
bone Arthur blank.
They're extraordinary people.
Jack Welch's and extraordinary,
extraordinary human being.
One of the ways I would describe it is I would never take a phone call from him
sitting down the energy just immediately you stood up to provide an answer to
Jack.
And,
uh,
just I've got a lot of,
he was hugely helpful to me while I was the CEO at home depot.
Got a lot of stories around Jack Trilly a hero.
Yeah,
let's get into it.
This is a long form podcast,
so we have the luxury of time.
So,
so,
so this is an arc.
This is,
uh,
so I become CEO,
the Home Depot,
I think.
Uh,
all right,
I'm going to call Jack and I'm going to ask him for some time and kind of give
me CEO one on one lessons and which I did.
And he was very nice.
He was down in Florida at the time.
I said,
Jack,
can I spend a day with you and you know,
kind of pick your brains?
And he said,
great.
And my do.
I have done hundreds of pitches to Jack in my time at Ge and I prepared so hard
for this meeting with him.
I could tell you the margin rate of an ant trap.
I mean,
I was just into all the details,
all the numbers,
and I go down and the first thing he says is,
um,
draw me your org chart and we spend a day going through people and it was
probably one of the most helpful days of my time because you know,
and I recommend this for anybody anywhere.
If you find somebody that you really respect,
who will ask you questions and then you just listen to what you're saying.
And in effect,
he did that,
uh,
for me on the organization and the people.
And then every year I do the same thing.
I'd spend a day with Jack every single year and this is jumping ahead,
but I loved the story.
So,
so the eighth year,
so my last time I get to ask the question that's sort of the moron,
stupid question that you wouldn't dare ask earlier cause you wouldn't be able to
get the next meeting with Jack.
So I go,
okay Jacques,
all of the attributes of leadership,
if you had to weigh them all and pick one,
what is the single most important attribute of leadership?
And His answer shocked me.
Uh,
he said generosity and I wouldn't have predicted it.
It kind of took me by surprise when he said it.
And then when he explained it and explained how as leaders you need to be fueled
by the success of others and how that's really got to be the driving force.
And I could see that as true for how he ran GE,
um,
made a lot of sense.
And it stuck with me ever since I was a great lesson.
Why was it important in that first meeting that he shifted the focus to the org
chart?
What happened?
What were the questions he asked?
What were the important?
So the great questions were,
uh,
first,
how are you organized?
I mean,
cause you know,
that tells a lot about what your priorities are.
And second,
uh,
he'd be asking about people and I'd be,
I'd find myself in some instances,
it kind of making excuses and saying,
well,
you know,
blah,
blah blah,
but not really.
And then he'd just say,
I mean,
did you hear what you just said?
Where are you going to do about it?
And it wasn't his commentary on these people and he didn't even know them.
But listening to his,
you know,
feeding back to me what I was saying and then say,
hey look,
you know,
you're not smart enough to do this on your own.
So if you're going to do this and be successful,
you gotta you gotta get the right team with you
as well.
For people who don't know,
Jack,
what would you say he is best known for?
Uh,
it's something that stuck with me and I have great respect for Jack and I've
read a lot about him,
but I might be getting the details wrong because it's been a while.
Uh,
I mean he said the nickname neutron Jack,
he,
I think it was what the bottom 10% of performers and Ge were let go on an annual
basis and basis.
And was he then asking you about strongest weakest performers and then asking
you why you are keeping or why the weakest performers were continuing to be
employed?
Wasn't doing it on a kind of percentage.
Tell me who you know,
who lags and who's a head.
It was more individual by individual.
Tell me,
describe for me the strengths and weaknesses go through it.
Um,
and what I would say that what Jack did that,
um,
particularly impresses me in retrospect because it's so hard to do.
Um,
so I'm,
I go into GE as a lawyer.
Uh,
GE is a finance engineering firm.
Lawyers are not,
I mean,
you know,
we had a great legal team,
uh,
but it still,
the lawyers are not at the top of the organizational pecking order.
Somehow.
Jack Gut,
the sense within me that the path to success and the company was actually to
disagree with him and be right.
And that's huge because,
and he would say this,
uh,
you know,
I,
I express,
wow,
that's so amazing.
You know,
in retrospect,
Jack,
that's so amazing.
And he'd say,
well,
I really don't need to pay people to tell me I'm right.
I need to pay people who are going to tell me where I'm wrong.
But organizations are such echo chambers.
And Bernie Marcus gave me a great piece of advice.
He gave me tons of pieces of advice that were terrific.
But I remember one of them at the start of becoming CEO,
Bernie said,
okay,
let me tell you how this works.
You're going to be sitting around a table and you're going to tell a joke and
all the folks are going to laugh.
And he said,
let me tell you you're not fun.
And the port at the point of that is people are just going to respond to you the
way they think.
You want
them to respond.
So eliciting the kind of reaction that Jack did for me,
which was,
hey,
it's okay actually to disagree with the boss.
You damn well better be right.
But it's a good thing to disagree with the bosses.
Huge.
So on that point a,
and
I may get the pronunciation wrong,
Carol to me.
Yeah.
So at the time home depot,
the CFO said that when you arrived still,
and this is a compliment,
you invited conflict into the decision making process.
Uh,
and I'll quote here is from a fortune article,
we were conflict hesitant.
Frank asked a ton of questions that make you say,
what is working and not working?
So this is interesting to me.
Uh,
how do you encourage people and to disagree and elicit the bad news or whatever
it might be?
How do you do that without also simultaneously or dissipating the fear of
getting punished for that?
Uh,
I think it's one of the most important thing.
So,
so I have a long discussion around what the inverted pyramid means,
but one of the things it means is that everything that's important as the CEO,
everything that's important is happening above you with the customers and the
front line associates and the folks who,
you know,
work in the organization.
So you've got to figure out a way to effectively listen and effectively get them
to communicate to you.
I learned actually from a board member at home depot at this may be more unique
to retail to doing this,
but it worked.
Uh,
the,
the best way to do that is if I was walking in a store and we had a particular
project,
my comment would be,
why isn't project x working?
And then they'd go,
oh my gosh,
frank knows that the project isn't working.
I guess we better say something.
And so that would actually prompt a conversation while if you said,
how's everything going in any organization of any size?
There's only one right answer.
When the boss says,
how's everything going?
The answer is it's going great.
You're awesome.
Please go.
And you need to kind of pull out from people,
you know,
every once in a while somebody would say,
why did you say it's not working?
It's working great.
But more often than not it would be,
oh well here's,
here's what you're missing.
Here's what's not happening.
Here are the issues.
So,
so there are so many pieces of paper as you can see.
So many questions that I want to ask.
And uh,
the next,
the next one is really closely related to this.
And something that I think about a lot,
and I'll lead into it in a somewhat confusing way,
but the internet is almost all negative feedback.
People get punished and attacked.
However,
if you look at say,
opera and classical conditioning,
dog training,
mammal training,
human training,
positive reinforcement is actually critically important.
Uh,
so this is a,
as a quote,
and please correct me if I'm wrong,
but I'd love to get some examples of how you have celebrated people's successes
and wins,
whether within home depot or elsewhere.
And,
uh,
the quote is,
I'm a lawyer.
Lawyers don't celebrate shit.
MMM.
Or actually,
furthermore,
the only way people know what you want is that you celebrate when they get it.
Right.
I'm a lawyer.
Lawyers don't celebrate shit.
So how,
how,
what are concrete examples of how you would do that?
I,
that was actually one of my biggest learnings of the time as CEO was the
importance of celebration.
In fact,
what I tell people now is,
you know,
every business person knows the saying that you get what you measure.
I'd say there's an important,
maybe even more important corollary.
You get what you celebrate.
People just as you say,
uh,
they reference off of the stories they reference off of when you reward someone
and make a point of it.
Uh,
that actually sticks in the mind long after other things have forgotten.
And at,
uh,
at depot we did a lot,
in fact,
spent a lot of time on this.
Uh,
personally I would spend every Sunday afternoon writing notes to hourly
associates.
So for us,
customer service was what we were after.
Customer service is such a vague right,
such a vague term.
And I would write a hundred to 200 notes every Sunday and we had a whole process
for rolling up,
you know,
the Joan Jane Jack did blank and it would roll up from the store to the district
to the region and I would write notes,
st gear,
Joe or Jane and it wouldn't just be you're awesome.
Thank you very much frank.
It would be,
I heard you did blank and I'd write out what it was.
Thank you very much.
And uh,
send the note out and signed my name.
And as a I,
I does a long,
I have a long thing about note writing and why note writing important.
Okay.
But so I wondered about the power of that.
But early on I was walking a store and associate came up to me and said,
um,
gee,
would you mind rewriting the note that you sent me?
And I said,
no,
sure,
no problem,
but why?
And he said,
well,
we were all convinced that it was a rowboat pen note.
And so we put it under water and it leaked.
It ran.
And so would you like me another,
uh,
people people respond to being recognized?
I learned this from,
so I,
early in my career I worked for George Bush Dad when he was vice president.
And it's a great thing to work.
I mean,
he's a wonderful human being.
Working for the vice president is great because it's a very small staff so you
can actually see what he does.
And at the time,
so this is in 1981 ages and ages ago,
no computers.
But he would come into the office and type out notes and you knew that he was
typing the notes because you know,
the,
he would be slightly off and the be white out.
But as a staff member,
when you got a note from the vice president,
you know you're walking home will water.
I mean if you just felt like everything was great and uh,
I believe that we learn more from those positive stories and recognition than
anything else.
In addition,
I mean the notes were kind of my thing,
but we also did a video every single week of great customer service and we put
it in that same break room TV and you'd videotape the actual,
the associates who we rebate highlight the story.
We'd retell the story with the associates.
I mean,
so there'd be one of these every single week.
We did little books of great associate customer service stories.
We have,
if you go into stores,
you'll see people with badges and recognition and it's um,
it is,
you just don't communicate.
You can write a memo to someone and think it gets down to an organization,
but it doesn't,
it's when you pull people out and say,
here,
this is what this person did that was extraordinary.
You tell a story around it and everyone remembers that story.
That person's thrilled and everybody else is going,
I want a story told about me too.
I'm doing that kind of stuff as well and it builds on itself.
So if you have,
I think the number that you mentioned was 350,000 or a few hundred thousand or
350,000 now there are over four,
right?
So if you have 350,000 associates and you're doing this every week,
how,
what are the check boxes or the process for selecting those 200 I'd love to
learn more about that because I had no doubt there are people listening to this.
I know there are people listening to this who run very large organizations and
the the at that,
that's going to be one of the questions top of mind.
I would imagine.
So the great thing about it is you take,
so you take that,
so you say frank wants to send a note out.
Then this is where having an organization is great because then you say,
okay,
here's how we're going to do it.
The stores are going to submit stories of great customer service in the store.
We'll submit that to the district and the district will take its best stories
and the district's best stories go to the regions and then the regions all
submit them to me.
So beyond the note writing itself,
there's actually a process for recognition.
So I hope the better store managers,
we're recognizing every single story that they forwarded onto the district and
we're making a celebration with their associates in that store.
Same with the districts and same with the region so that it reinforced itself.
Uh,
so it's not just the one note,
it's the entire process.
It's why as I say,
the people just should spend time thinking about what they're recognizing and
celebrating.
They should do it intentionally.
They should have a process around it.
They should do it consistently.
Because you know,
we talk a lot about company culture,
but that's what really sets the culture.
It's what everybody is saying.
You want to know,
you want to see the story.
We want to see what this looks like.
This is what it looks like.
And so if,
if these letters are going out and people want to receive a letter,
they want to be in the video.
Right.
Uh,
what were the criteria for good stories?
In other words,
these various say district managers,
so on could have their subjective views of what makes a good customer service
story.
But did you give them any guidelines at all?
Uh,
not,
I didn't,
I'll be honest.
I mean,
customers,
that's the important thing about customer service is,
um,
it takes lots of different forms,
right?
But,
um,
what we weren't looking for is,
and it's not like this isn't important,
but we weren't looking for the story of the cashier who stopped the robber.
I mean,
so those are important stories,
but it,
you know,
some companies are more focused on shrink prevention and things like that.
We were focused on customer service and we had lots of different,
I mean,
just emotionally powerful people helping other people in the store.
Um,
phenomenal,
phenomenally strong stories.
But no,
didn't set any guidelines.
So you mentioned,
uh,
you know,
the,
the bay stuffing,
the bankrupt,
not the bank robbery,
but the theft.
All right.
Not being a very good example.
And with this brings to mind for me is,
I think it was Andy Grove of Intel.
I might be getting this wrong.
I'm sure someone on the Internet will correct me if I am,
but that for every metric they decided to measure for,
which was a positive indicator for the company,
Andy would insist that they identify the PR,
the perverse incentive or correlating metric that they should measure,
right.
For side effects.
Right.
And so you could,
I mean,
I'm reaching a little bit here,
but you could see if someone says this,
of course this is exaggerated,
but oh my God,
I could get in the video if I stop a robbery,
like who could I,
who can I hire to simulate a robbery?
Uh,
and I'll let my buddy go,
but it,
I'll put up a good fight and get it in the video.
Uh,
how did you,
you mentioned the,
what you,
uh,
what you celebrate or I'm sorry,
the,
let me get this right.
It just wrote it down.
But,
uh,
effectively you get what you measure,
you get what you celebrate,
right?
Uh,
what were some of the,
when you took the rans,
what were some of the metrics that,
that you focused on or that the organization focused on?
Yeah.
Uh,
so every retailer,
I mean now it's commonplace,
you look at what's called net promoter score.
Uh,
but that,
I mean the,
if that's an accurate Andy grove quote,
I entirely agree with it because,
um,
it's definitely a quote from someone,
definitely a quote from someone in a white quote.
Cause every single metric does have a germ of a problem in it.
So you have to be careful.
I mean,
we would measure net promoter score,
you know,
how happy the customers are in the store.
Uh,
but it's always a reminder that the dominant measure is how are we doing on
sales and profitability.
So as you move down below that,
on the metric side,
you'd have to be very careful
and how did you measure sales?
But there are many different ways to doing it.
A revenue,
you have revenue per square foot,
you have say a profit or revenue or net income,
whatever it might be per employee.
You have many different approaches.
You could take,
were there any that were more important than others?
No,
I mean we,
our stores,
uh,
fall,
they're very idiosyncratic within the box.
Uh,
they're very similar and we just,
we would look at,
uh,
so we didn't have to get very sophisticated about on the store side,
on revenue per square foot of the merchandising side.
You do more of that because you'd want to say,
what's our,
what's our return on the space where we're allocating to that merchandise?
See,
you'd mentioned,
uh,
at least once,
maybe a few times how he seemed to be the accidental CEO.
Didn't expect to be asked to be CEO.
How did they explain it or if they didn't?
I'm sure they probably said something.
Why?
Why were you asked to be CEO?
Uh,
well,
uh,
that's in the end you need to ask Ken Langone,
who is the lead director and the other directors of Home Depot at the time.
I've never really spent time asking them why.
Uh,
I think they had seen a lot of me because,
uh,
I was in charge of deals and we did a lot of Amazon transactions.
The SVP,
senior vice president of corporate business development or that was it?
That was that a GE?
Well,
I did deals.
So my,
the job I ended up with at Ge was doing m and a,
the job I was doing at home depot was doing m and a.
We went out and we bought,
uh,
a whole series of companies called at the time home depot supply that became,
that was the largest commercial industrial distributor in the country,
the first,
but I pitched those deals to the board.
So they saw me a lot.
And then the first thing I did when I became CEO and said,
we need to sell this business and we sold the business.
Why did you have to sell the business?
Or why did you recommend that they sell the business?
So,
um,
the dominant reason for me personally was,
uh,
and I think that this was organizationally right,
but I know it was right for me individually was saying,
to be the best retailer in any space requires 110% of the effort.
For me to be the best leader of a retailer is a 110% plus of effort.
No chance that I can also say,
oh,
and here's this other business,
this,
you know,
great commercial and industrial distribution business.
I can be the best CEO in that space to just knew that was not going to be
possible.
And So said we need to sell.
Is that what you said?
To convince the board that it was a good idea or a much,
yeah,
pretty much.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
And said,
and it was,
I don't think I made it that personal where I think I said,
look,
the cause the company we'd been losing market share.
Uh,
we were trailing our principal competitor.
I said,
this is,
um,
we've got to be all eyes on the retail business and we got to get rid of
everything that's a distraction of the retail business plus at the time.
Uh,
so I took over right at the start of 2007 and the housing crisis was,
you know,
by that point,
the clouds were fairly obvious.
And so we knew we had to make some dramatic changes because things were going to
go downhill fast and they went even more downhill and faster or anticipate.
I bought a house in late 2007 til it got good time.
There you go.
In San Jose,
Aka man,
Jose,
California,
but it's a separate story.
Uh,
the decision to divest of like is HD supply.
Yup.
And I may be misattributed so please correct me if I'm wrong,
but it,
it is also makes me think of Jack Welch if I'm getting this right,
which is,
did he not want every division or product line or company to be either number
one or number two in its category or
famously had that as an objective that did not drive that decision because home
depot supply was number one.
Right.
Got It.
So it's more a matter of focus.
So it was a matter of focus.
And in fact a,
I mean my commentary was,
um,
there are some unique individuals like Jack who can run a conglomerate and I
would be deep,
deep into the details of the business I worked at in Ge.
And Jack would still ask questions to me that I had just slapped my head and go,
oh my God,
what a great question.
Why didn't I think of that?
I knew not me.
I mean,
it would take,
but take all,
as I said,
just running a conglomerate is,
it is a big,
big challenge.
And that one I knew I couldn't do that.
Uh,
so you mentioned,
uh,
we'll,
we've,
we've talked a bit about your legal background and uh,
someone compared to your one point,
Darwin Smith,
the attorney turns CEO at Kimberly Clark,
uh,
because of how lawyers are trained in conflict,
how to navigate deeper issues,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
I've also noticed that for instance,
if I can't find a proofreader who is a professional writer,
I will ask one of my friends who is a lawyer because they're very good.
They're not professional proofreaders per say for the type of writing that I do,
but they're very good at spotting language.
That is nebulous words.
It shouldn't be there.
Uh,
how did your legal training help you for what came later?
And it might be a chicken and the egg thing.
I mean it could be what helps you to be a good lawyer,
but,
uh,
what about those life experiences or that training helped you later or hurt?
I think,
uh,
I think the part of so the hurt is easier.
So you start there.
Yeah.
So the,
so the,
the things that I kind of had to hike away from our,
uh,
for lawyers,
everything is great right there and you can chew over decisions for a long time
and it's very complex and full of ambiguity.
If you're leading a 350,000 people strong and you're calling out and your
statements are in paragraphs,
I'd be just,
cause you've lost it right from the start.
So driving for simple portable messages that just,
you know,
screw the ambiguity,
uh,
that is essential.
I actually think it's essential regardless of whether it's 350,000 people or
three people,
so that you kind of have to train away from.
The part that's probably good is,
uh,
you're trained to worry.
I mean,
lawyers are trained.
I always felt like law school trains you to worry about things that no normal
human being would worry about.
And so there is a value,
there is a value as a CEO to worry you,
but you've got to kind of internalize that as much as possible.
Uh,
because the other part of you have to get rid of that worry.
Colin Powell has a great expression that I deeply believe in,
which is optimism is a force multiplier.
And in any organization you got to bend.
This was particularly true as things were grim.
You've,
you've got to drive to the optimistic side.
You can't be going on,
you know.
Got It.
Yeah.
It's just really good.
Turn out badly.
Uh,
so,
um,
but I think internally that's helpful to worry,
to be thinking around the corner to be thinking what's going to go wrong.
Just as you said,
get that.
Every metric that you put in place comes with its own little seed of
destruction.
Understanding that,
being aware of it,
don't tell it to anybody else.
So,
you know,
we would,
all our stores would have net promoter scores.
I wouldn't tell them,
oh,
here's the fascinating flaw in that metric and why you might not want to be
committed to that.
We just go,
this is what we're focused on.
We're focused on our net promoter score.
So there,
oh,
I'm sorry.
Okay.
I was going to,
uh,
I'm going to zoom out,
but I want to zoom in for a second.
Just a net promoter score.
How did,
how did you,
uh,
how did you all measure that?
It was by surveys in,
at after on the receipt in the store.
And so you can immediately imagine if so,
so not to get into the nitty gritty of what could along with net promoter
scores,
but you can imagine one of the things is the more,
um,
crowded your store is,
the more volume your store does.
By and large,
that correlated to a net promoter score that was a little bit lower,
right?
If you wanted the highest net promoter score,
have a store that very few people what do,
uh,
right.
So one customer per employee per day.
Right,
exactly.
And they were thrilled.
It may take a little,
you know,
give,
give you the positive feedback.
But yeah,
we did it straight off of 'em,
straight off of receipts and people typing in and saying whether they're happy
or they weren't happening.
And then,
you know,
now on the Internet,
obviously a lot easier,
lot easier.
Four C surveys come up all the time.
It's also a lot easier to,
uh,
as you noted,
get lost in the seeds of destruction or the noise,
right.
Because if you have a net promoter score also,
at least of some types,
you can have a selection bias for people that are unhappy,
which is super,
super tough.
Yup.
Uh,
but the,
the zooming out,
uh,
I want to do right now and look at what you said about keeping,
keeping a lot of that worry and potential downside inside.
This is a,
a huge challenge for a lot of founders and CEOs that I know where they have to
really like put on the brave face and help everyone marched optimism while
keeping any of the concerns they might have insight or at least not showing it
publicly to all the troops.
Could you walk us through if possible or just describe maybe a period or an
instance where you had a lot of that to keep inside and how you dealt with that?
Because a lot of these CEO's felt really alone.
They end up in some cases getting health problems.
Uh,
it's very,
very challenging.
Uh,
could you give us a,
maybe an example of,
of how you've contended with that?
Uh,
the best thing for me,
I don't say there's a great saying in retail that now has to be amended because
of the Internet,
but the same retail is all truth is on the floor of the store.
So now it's also online,
but all truth,
it's on the floor of the store.
Um,
the best vehicle for me to deal with those worries was always spending time in
the store.
And I would try,
I don't think I didn't do it religiously every week,
but I would do,
um,
dinners with hourly associates whenever I'd,
you know,
wherever I was,
I tried to do one a week,
um,
with hourly associates and you pretty quickly get your problems put in
perspective and it was hugely valuable to me.
And I remember the first one I did was if we fly in and I'm sitting around,
there's this very nice woman sitting next to me,
you know,
kind of give or take my age and I'm complaining about my back.
So I,
you know,
she says how you're doing.
And I was saying something with my back,
my dry flown in a private plane and I'm saying,
I got my back problems and then I go,
how are you?
And she said,
well,
you know,
it's funny that you say that about your back problem because you know,
three months ago I fractured my spine and I had to be in traction and it was
really difficult when I started working in the store again and I was in a
wheelchair.
And you know,
we have bulky items and they have to get moved or,
and I'm going,
I'm complaining about the little.
And then she says,
and I go,
wow,
that's amazing.
And then she said,
well,
that wasn't the really hard part.
The really hard part was I have a 12 year old developmentally disabled son and I
had to pay that.
I have to pay them every day and I have to get them in the bath.
And that was so difficult when I was in the wheelchair.
The fears and worries kind of melt when you see what people are putting up with
every day and doing one foot in front of the other and having a smile and being
committed and to people around.
And so that gave a sense of perspective that sort of put the earnings per share
worries a little bit,
a little bit in farther focus.
And they were always great for that.
I mean,
just amazing home depot and,
and both Bernie and Ken Arthur as well.
Uh,
the great stories of Home Depot and wide built from scratch and such a great
book.
Why it's such a great idea is some crazy stories in that book.
But I mean,
they're great.
They're just,
the underlying thing is people who,
you know,
typically start,
I come in,
I'm shagging carts in a lot.
I,
you know,
maybe I graduated from high school,
I'm not really sure why I'm doing this job.
And you know,
80% of our store managers started as hourly associates.
Our upper management started as hourly associates.
And it's these amazing,
uh,
career stories,
wealth generation through starting at the bottom in retail.
I was at dinner last week with a friend.
This I think happens all the time with Bernie and Canon Arthur.
But it was,
you know,
if you go,
boy,
there's a bell to ring in life.
This guy comes up with and he's with his daughter and he said,
uh,
I just wanted to introduce my daughter to you cause I want to introduce her to
the person who's making her college possible.
And you go,
wow.
I mean,
first off,
obviously not me.
But wow,
that's,
that is such an awesome story.
And that story is replicated over and over and over and over again at home
depot.
And it was uh,
both Bernie and Kenton,
the north always talk about the home depot,
you know,
you're going to have your mission statement and all the rest of the way.
It's really about as wealth generation for your associates and it ties back if
it ties back to Jack's comment about leadership,
that that if,
if,
if the end you could say,
wow,
these people made their lives and careers from it,
that provides a great perspective on the job
after leaving home depot.
Since that time,
how have you created a pressure release valve for the worrying or a stress?
Uh,
the first great thing about retirement is the anxiety level drops dramatically.
So,
so,
uh,
the,
if you were in boots every day,
you know the thing about a retail businesses on your phone there,
your sales and the it organization is saying,
Gee,
I can give you this by the minute.
No,
I really don't want it.
Excuse me.
I don't want it by the minute.
So that anxiety of everyday home depot just a report,
its results and there great results.
And uh,
Craig Menear and so CEO now is doing a phenomenal job.
But it is that every day,
every day pressure on delivery.
Uh,
that's good to step away from and good to think about.
What are the,
some of the other things you want to do in your life and um,
focus some time elsewhere.
What else when it creeps in.
Is there anything that you like to do,
any particular sports or morning routines or anything that you find helpful for
managing your state?
Uh,
there are lots of,
there are lots of things
cause I think your retirement is busier than most people's careers in some
respects.
I mean you,
you,
you certainly keep yourself occupied.
So I'd be curious to hear what,
what routines,
habits or
ah,
so the habits are very different now.
I,
I think probably I had a very non,
uh,
pretty much because of starting without a preset set of notions of what I was
going to do at home depot.
If you asked me what I did at the start of every day as CEO of Home Depot?
No,
it's the con comparing contrast.
Let's,
let's,
let's do both.
All right.
You're okay with that?
So,
yeah,
so the,
so,
and I'm not recommending this.
This is not a good tool,
but I started every day,
uh,
reading emails from customers and I did that because,
um,
because in any large organization,
it's really easy to get a false sense from averages and percents.
And then you see a,
wow,
we did that badly and it's a good,
it was a good marker for me of how we were doing and what we needed to focus on.
And that kind of management by anecdote is actually pretty powerful.
But I would do that for like an hour early in the morning.
I have always gotten up really,
really early.
Wasn't like what time is early.
So I get up about quarter of five and I'd usually be in the office by six
o'clock and,
you know,
start reading emails.
Now I don't,
I still get up really early.
Uh,
now instead,
uh,
I start by,
by reading.
Um,
uh,
my wife and I,
at this was a habit introduced and,
uh,
and um,
I'm not,
I,
I struggle with the notion of an intentional God.
My wife does not.
My wife is a strong believer in an intentional God and we pray in the morning
together and,
uh,
it was awkward.
You know,
I'm a New England does just,
you know,
oh gosh,
if we don't do anything with anyone that,
that level of intimacy and,
uh,
that's actually really an interesting habit to have.
Uh,
because saying things aloud and hearing what's in her mind,
uh,
and then,
you know,
sort of being forced in yourself,
okay,
what foot do,
what am I grateful for?
What am I seeking help for is,
is really,
is really valuable.
Um,
so that's a different,
different kinds of habits.
So what is the format?
You don't have to share the specifics unless you're open to doing that,
but what is the format of,
of the prayer?
How long does it last?
And you mentioned maybe some,
some sneak peaks,
but I'd love to hear about that because,
uh,
I journal almost every morning.
Yeah.
And it's,
I'm not speaking aloud,
but there,
there might be some commonalities.
Yeah,
no,
I suspect.
What is the format that you use?
So the format is there.
There's actually,
we have,
there's a lectionary that tells you what readings.
So there are a series of readings.
So you do a reading typically from the Old Testament,
the psalms and the new testaments typically how you got.
So we read and then we pray.
And my prayers,
I've gotten better at it,
you know,
because I do think to the extent you write it down and you say things,
it kind of gives context.
And maybe in some way it makes it more likely to happen.
My prayers that tended to be,
you know,
I hope everything works out.
And boy am I grateful for everything.
My wife would be very specific about,
uh,
and is very specific about this person needs help.
Uh,
this is what I'm going to do to try to help this person.
My wife,
I've paranthetically,
um,
worked for habitat for humanity.
That was her job.
And she goes to Haiti nearly every other,
well,
every month for a while.
She's going almost every other week.
So she's,
um,
she does a lot for other people,
but she will mention,
here's,
here are the people who are in need.
Here's what,
and um,
so it's really helpful seeing,
okay,
that's what she's focused on.
And then it teases out from me,
what should I be focused on?
Who needs help?
What should I be doing?
So if,
if people,
if someone were transcribing your prayers with,
would there be certain categories that tend to pop up more than others?
Like somebody who needs help and how I'm going to have to,
I'm grateful for,
I need help with X.
Are there,
are there particular buckets that tend to pop up a lot?
It's,
it's,
uh,
other people who need help.
Uh,
we had,
there's a separate thing of each time kind naming two things we're grateful for
and what are we grateful for?
And it can be,
I'm grateful to be on Tim Ferriss' podcast.
I'm Greg crave.
I,
it's,
uh,
but it's,
it's a good mental exercise to say,
Hey,
there was an enormous amount of stuff to be grateful for.
And then there are people who need help and it's,
um,
and my wife has a much more powerful prayer than I am,
but I'm learning,
I'm getting there.
I really,
I really liked that.
I don't,
I don't pray in the morning,
although maybe someone would,
uh,
would consider what I do a secular prayer perhaps.
But I do have a gratitude journal and I note the three things that I'm grateful
for first thing in the morning.
And then I have a handful of prompts that take four to five minutes,
find the am,
and then I do a review in the PM,
including what am I grateful for that happened today effectively.
Uh,
it's,
it's very deceptively powerful.
Exactly right.
And like you mentioned,
uh,
or maybe I'm implying or inferring,
it also helps to develop the lens through which you view the rest of the day.
Right?
If you buy a car and then all of a sudden you go out and you see your car
everywhere,
it's not because everyone went out and copied you and bought your car.
It's because you have that attuned,
selective attention.
Uh,
it's,
it's really,
really powerful.
Uh,
it's a powerful way to get to learn about another person too.
So to get that sense of,
oh,
okay,
Yup.
This is what they're worried about.
This is how they think.
It's really useful.
I really love that it starts with somebody else who needs help and then grateful
for,
yeah.
In the sense that it's not right off the bat beginning with your ask.
That's a really important,
yep.
You mentioned checking or reading customer email.
So I had read on,
I think it was consumers.com is probably elsewhere,
but you gave out your phone number and email and uh,
I think that,
uh,
this is,
this is the line that I found on consumerist.
Use it.
If you have a persistent problem with home depot that hasn't been resolved
through normal customer service channels,
remember to be polite,
professional,
and to the point.
And then there's a phone number,
extension,
Dah,
Dah.
You can also email frank_blake@homedepot.com.
How on earth do you triage that?
Did,
did you get fewer email and expected fewer phone calls?
Did you get diluted what happened?
Yeah,
there's a lot.
And we have a team.
Uh,
I mean I think it was hugely important to do.
I did it early on.
I still get customer emails.
Uh,
but we set up an executive resolution's team and you know,
I'm not,
uh,
I learned,
I learned the first weekend on the job when I mistakenly answered my phone,
not thinking and got a customer that,
you know,
those take a long time to get resolved.
So you have,
so we have a professional team,
uh,
that goes through those and resolves them.
And um,
but for me what was useful was you see patterns and you go,
okay,
this is what's not going well at.
This is consistent.
We're just,
it may not be numerically that,
you know,
percentage wise that high.
But if somebody is taking time out of their day to email the CEO saying this is
screwed up,
it's worth listening to.
And then associates also knew my email and they send me,
you know,
hey,
this isn't going well.
If you've got to fix this,
you got to fix that,
whatever.
What,
what,
uh,
what are some of your favorite interactions or,
or better put lessons learned,
tidbits of wisdom received from Bernie?
Marcus,
you said you learned a lot.
So are there any that come to aligned?
Uh,
it could be anything where you were like,
wow,
that's really useful.
Um,
the,
the first is,
uh,
just as I said about avoiding the echo chamber,
getting outside of the Echo Chamber,
uh,
Bernie,
has a
crate.
I think one of the things that makes home depot such a strong culture is that
one of Bernie's other early on comments to me was,
um,
look,
you have a prominent job but you don't have a significant job.
You have prominent job cause you go out and talk to analysts and all the rest of
it,
but the only significant job,
so the job so that people who are helping customers and so everything you do and
that again,
it goes back to the inverted pyramid.
Everything you do is in support of your frontline associates and your customers.
And that's how you have to think about the orientation of,
of your business.
Bernie also the quote unquote headquarters and Home Depot is not called the
headquarters.
Uh,
it's called the store support center.
That's not that unusual in retail,
but it's a real,
the idea is you're there to support the store.
That's what you're there to do.
What are some of the other ingredients?
Those could be preexisting.
So before,
before you arrived or changes that you and your team help to,
to make,
uh,
that helped foster the orange apron cult,
that sort of,
that dedication to customer service because it seems,
at least based on what I'd read that you,
you really paid a lot of attention to.
I'm not going to say resurrecting it,
but really reinforcing that as a core differentiator.
I,
so it goes through,
I mean,
I,
it starts with,
um,
and again this is,
this is another Bernie Ism,
but,
uh,
you,
you need to take care of your associates.
And so,
uh,
even when things were really tough and the housing downturn,
we were giving our hourly associates pay raises and bonuses when we weren't in
the,
in the store support center,
we pay our assistant store managers get stock grants,
um,
which I don't think any other retailer anywhere near the home depot size.
And now those stock grants,
you know,
those are worth a lot of money.
Uh,
so getting them bought into an understanding that the success of the company is
their success as well.
Also on pay,
we,
uh,
we have a very,
we instituted a very strong success sharing programs.
So,
you know,
if your store does well,
the associates get an extra bonus.
Um,
all of those things to say,
look,
I can't expect an associate to care about paying attention to the customer if
the company isn't caring about the associates.
Uh,
we did lots of other programs and then a lot on the recognition and reward side
to reinforce the culture of the company.
But you do actually have to focus on how pay people to yeah,
I mean,
you know,
there's only so much you can do
without addressing.
You got to be creating opportunities for wealth generation for your team.
And that's what's got to be,
as I said,
that's what's got to be exciting to you and what's gotta to be driving
[inaudible] uh,
one of the,
one of the bullets that was suggested to me as a point to explore with you,
it's in fact the number one that was suggested by this friend of mine is
accountability.
And now this is what he wrote.
Every time something went wrong,
he took responsibility even right before he left home depot and the trends,
uh,
even right before he left home depot and a transition plan was set up,
there was,
there was a security breach,
I think it's 56 million credit card numbers or so.
And frank took the blame also fix things fast.
He has uncanny self awareness quite separately.
I had wanted to chat about this.
So the incident response room that was set up on the 20th floor of Home Depot,
not headquarters,
the store support center,
how did you handle that crisis?
What was your thinking process?
Can you just take us through that?
Because,
uh,
I really like to kind of explore the macro by digging into the micro.
So should we,
maybe we can talk about this.
Uh,
so home depot,
we had a data breach in,
um,
September of 2014,
uh,
in the sort of Ironic,
commentary in August,
we had actually spent a half a day going through with our board why we thought
we were in pretty good shape and weren't going to have a data breach.
But,
uh,
obviously,
obviously we did,
uh,
we had a couple of,
um,
so once we knew,
uh,
we went out and made a public announcement right away.
Uh,
and my principals were,
and I don't,
I've,
I,
I think there was a very nice article written on,
Hey,
you've accepted accountability for this.
And another way to look at it is,
well,
I mean really,
I mean you had to,
I mean I that wasn't the not a serious choice.
Uh,
and understand,
and this is where it actually helped being a lawyer and understand that the help
that the lawyers are going to give you is not help because the lawyers are going
to say things like,
well don't admit that you did anything wrong because then you're going to be
subject to litigation and all the rest and you got to understand that actually
all that matters is taking care of your customers.
So I actually gave the Pan,
I said nothing is going to be written about what we do here from our legal team.
Love our legal team.
We had great lawyers but it's all going to be written by our person in charge of
communications.
And all we're going to talk about is as a customer you're not liable and here's
what we're doing for you.
And then we just decided we were going to be completely transparent.
So every time we knew something we said something,
it was really painful because the nature of these things is that you don't
really know what's going on.
It unfolds over time.
So we'd have one release after another.
It felt like we were constantly,
uh,
in the barrel,
but I think,
uh,
people appreciated that we were being transparent and focused on taking care of
our customer and we didn't really see any significant decline.
Was that a difficult or an easy conversation to have in terms of how you were
choosing to respond?
Do you remember like sitting down and having that first conversation or any of
those?
I do.
We set out here are,
here are three principles.
It's the only thing that matters is how we communicate to the customers.
The second thing is I tell people just recognize it.
The second principle is recognize no one is going to say massive data breach at
home depot.
Everybody did things right,
so understand we screwed up.
Don't worry about that,
worry about fixing it.
And I was really pleased and I give a lot of credit to our CIO at the time.
Met Carrie.
I was really pleased that the experts who kind of came in and cleaned up the
situation,
uh,
said that they saw less finger pointing CYA activity with home depot than
anybody else.
Uh,
so it was,
hey,
let's just move forward and get this thing fixed.
Um,
and uh,
we've,
we got through it.
It wasn't,
uh,
I mean I,
there wasn't a lot of discussion about weighing other alternative approaches.
I was very fortunate because my board was entirely supportive of how we handled
it.
Um,
so
I would imagine having the legal credentials that you do also helps because you
can think about it from the perspective of a general counsel,
but the executive decision to do something different.
Exactly.
And know that in the end the value gained from that is modest in terms of the
value potentially lost by not being straightforward with,
with your customers.
In fact,
they are lawyer was 110% behind that too.
You mentioned the three principles.
Could you review them for us?
Yeah.
So it's,
it was the customer as far as no Cya and fix the problem.
Yeah.
So recognize is related to a problem solving,
right?
It's like don't try to spin the facts might.
Yup.
Uh,
what,
were there any decisions that,
that,
that stick out for you as far as,
uh,
the,
the most difficult or one of the more difficult decisions,
conversations you've had to,
you had to have during your tenure at home depot?
Are there any particular difficult periods?
Because looking at your resume,
it's,
I can imagine quite a few people think to themselves,
oh my God,
this guy just bats a thousand.
Every time he steps up to the plate and find it very intimidating.
Uh,
I think with,
with,
with some,
uh,
you know,
understanding,
but
any particular difficult times,
it doesn't have to be at home depot.
In fact,
I mean,
another question I'd like to ask,
and if this is a,
an easier way to go about it,
it could be thrown at anytime your career,
but a favorite failure.
And when I mean by that is a failure that in some way set you up for later
success.
Uh,
is there any examples,
difficult times,
difficult decisions or,
uh,
failures that ended up being for the better?
So it's,
it's,
uh,
an embarrassing failure,
but I'll give a failure.
That was a great wake up for me.
Uh,
so before I became CEO,
one of the things I did for Home Depot's I did our real estate.
And um,
as I mentioned,
my son work at the company is still works at the company,
but at the time had just come back from Iraq and was starting working in a store
in depot and was given a,
I take a temporary store assistance manager or a store manager,
can't remember exactly which out in Colorado Springs.
So I fly out there to see him and he's there with four or five of his colleagues
from who'd also just returned from Iraq.
And they're telling the stories and I thought,
I worried about it as a parent,
but at the end of it I was just kind of overwhelmed by,
wow,
I didn't worry nearly enough these and,
and these people are just profoundly heroic.
So that was the dent.
Then in the morning I say,
great frank,
I drive out and see your store and brand new store.
So it was a store.
I was responsible for brand new store and great,
here's the address.
And so I'm driving out to the store.
I'd drive down,
I don't see it.
I kind of go three miles up.
Don't see it three miles back.
Don't see it.
Do it again,
do it again.
Finally I see it.
And the store is hidden by this massive berm along the roadway.
And there's this tiny little sign saying home depot and then the store itself,
uh,
you know,
if you know the construction of the store,
the store has beams where they shouldn't be.
I mean it was just,
and I go,
this was my job.
It was one,
we were doing 200 stores a year at the time.
This was my job.
This was a number.
I was just getting a number out to check my box.
And this is my son's damn store.
That's heartbreaking.
And my commentary to myself was personalize this,
make this personal feel.
It's personal.
You're some may not be doing every job,
but pretend that there's somebody,
you know,
there's,
there are people at the end of these decisions and focus on that and don't check
a number of box.
Uh,
uh,
as I say,
not,
not a happy mistake,
a failure,
but clearly a failure and one,
um,
hopefully,
hopefully I'll learn from.
So the,
the,
the word worry or worrying has come up quite a bit and it strikes me that
perhaps there are different species of worrying in the sense that there is maybe
passive worrying or something just eats at you and eats at you.
And it's,
as I heard someone say to me once,
uh,
worrying is praying for what you don't want it,
but,
and then perhaps there are other forms of worrying that are more active.
So when something is bothering it,
bothering you or you see a potential risk,
what is the thought process or the,
the next steps for you,
what,
what had you then take it out of your head so it's not just acid in the vessel
and do something with it.
Yeah.
And then any examples?
Well,
so there are different
parts of wiring then just as you said,
Tim,
there are lots of different ways of worrying on a personal level.
I,
you know,
I always found,
I just take the worry to,
okay,
here are a series of things that can go wrong.
Every single thing goes wrong.
And I mean,
you could ask my kids,
I joke,
I always figured I'd end up driving a taxi or an Uber.
Now just follow it all through and you're driving a taxi and eh,
you know,
that's not the end of the world.
And just deal with it that way.
Uh,
the more constructive worrying is,
uh,
when you,
when you actually try to break it down and say,
okay,
what am I worried about?
What?
And,
and typically the answer to that is take the worry from the generic and move it
to some level of ground engagement.
Go check it out.
Go figure out what's actually happening.
Odds are you'll be less worried.
And even if you're not less worried,
odds are you'll actually have an answer to how to deal with it.
So step number one is fact finding or,
yeah.
All right.
So,
uh,
I read a great book many years ago.
So this is another book that has traveled with me.
Yeah.
One of the others.
So along with,
uh,
the story of Home Depot,
there was one called how to stop worrying and start living by Dale Carnegie.
And
it's a fantastic book.
And one of the first steps is,
is this fact finding,
right?
Like don't assume that you're worried as well founded.
Don't assume you figured it out.
All right.
Go do some fact finding after you've done that,
whether you're,
let's say you,
perhaps you're less worried,
perhaps you're more worried,
but still worried nonetheless.
All right.
This is a legitimate risk.
What do you do then?
I,
so if you ask the people who work for me at home depot,
and it's sometimes joke about this,
that I just would,
doing anxiety transfer,
just go,
okay,
hey,
here's my observation.
This isn't going well.
You got it.
Yep.
You Go.
I had each rants and I think,
and that is my view of careers.
Careers exist.
People,
people progress in their lives through solving bigger and bigger problems.
So you can go here,
here's a problem,
here's what I see.
Here's a developmental opportunity for developmental opportunities.
See if you can go fix this.
Uh,
you know,
I was wondering,
as you said it would,
anxiety transfer would mean a friend of mine and he's a humorous,
also a fantastic writer named Aga Jacobs.
He rides for Esquire among many other things.
It does.
And at one point he was experimenting with outsourcing to India,
the Philippines and so on.
And he was trying to broaden the number of tasks that he could delegate to
someone else.
Keeping in mind that this is all a bit tongue in cheek and one of the things he
did,
because he is a real warrior,
uh,
and he decided to outsource is worrying.
So whether it was a book deadline or something else,
you would ask someone in Bangalore to worry about it for him.
And he told me,
he said it actually worldwide,
just to know that someone would worry about it on my behalf.
I love that.
That's terrific.
Outside of store,
what if,
if,
what advice did you give to your successor at Home Depot?
Was there,
did you have sort of a presidential meeting?
Like,
let me tell you a few things that I've learned in the trenches.
Few things to keep in mind.
Did you,
did you have that conversation?
Uh,
I'm sure.
I'm sure we did,
but I'm sure he also didn't need it.
And
let's say someone,
let's say that it were someone coming in fresh,
right?
So they,
they didn't have the experience with Home Depot.
What advice might you have given them,
uh,
aside from what we've discussed so far,
is there anything you would add?
I think it's,
it's,
um,
listening and how important listening,
communicating and getting your whatever it is you want as simply stated as
possible.
I'm,
uh,
so this is the other part of the legal side
is,
uh,
and I can't remember who said it,
but there is,
what you always want to get to is simplicity.
That's on the other side of complexity.
That's the goal for whatever it is you're working on.
And when you get there,
you know,
you've got it.
And you know,
you really understand it.
Um,
and whenever you find yourself just bound up in complexity,
you just know you haven't worked at hard enough.
How did you,
you'd mentioned the simple importable messaging.
Yeah.
Earlier.
How would you suggest someone develop that skill or how did you develop that
skill?
Think about stories I think is though is the way to start.
I mean,
uh,
listening to your podcast,
listening to how you tease out things from people.
It's in the end you remember stories.
And so if you said,
this is where I'm trying to go and this is the story around it,
uh,
you can get pretty simple portable messages.
Um,
slogans,
don't do it.
It's much,
much better if you can say,
here's the story,
here's what it,
here's what it looks like because people respond to the story.
Do you remember any stories that you've told that have had a particularly large
impact or that you've just received a lot of positive feedback,
uh,
about,
and it,
and it brings,
it hearkens back to you talking about reading these passages,
uh,
in your,
your very first sort of address the troops.
But are there any other moments that come to mind?
Could be one on one,
could be with a smaller group,
could be with the entire base of associates.
It's home depot related or more button.
Anything.
Alright,
so anything,
uh,
so one of the fun things or doing a post home depot is a,
is a podcast listening to yours and go cash.
These podcasts are fascinating.
So we do something called crazy good turns that talks about people who do crazy
good things for others.
And there are great,
I love it for lots of different reasons,
but here's the story.
So we've been doing it for three years and there's one human story.
All of the stories are wonderful,
but there's one in particular that I particularly love.
There's a woman,
uh,
she happens to live in Atlanta.
She's now around 70 years old when she was three years old and she's described
very poor circumstances.
And you know,
her mom leaves her in the apartment and goes across the street to get groceries.
She's in the apartment with her sister.
She's playing on the sofa.
She finds some matches down the cushion,
she'd lights them.
She's wearing cotton pajamas and she goes up like a match.
She's entirely on fire,
raced to the hospital,
third degree burns covering most of her.
And again,
this is now 65,
67 years ago.
Massive blood transfusions for required skin graphs.
Uh,
they put out an all point bulletin,
none a need for blood,
a truck driver driving through the town.
Here's this stops,
donates blood and donate skin.
And apparently the skin graft is like one of the most painful operations ever I
can imagine.
Gets into his truck and drives on and you go,
I go.
If that's not the best,
I've,
if that's not the best story ever of people doing something for someone else.
And then,
I mean,
just,
so that's my favorite.
Favorite story.
You mentioned post,
Post Home Depot.
What are you focused on these days?
Uh,
what types of projects or keeping you,
keeping your mind occupied?
So the,
so this crazy good turns podcast,
uh,
have,
a lot of fun with,
I don't do most of the work on that.
Uh,
the cofounder with me,
Bradshaw does the real work.
Um,
and we worked together at home depot and it goes to the message and the story
and what Brad did at home depot was a lot of that storytelling of how you get
these messages that are portable,
that people understand.
Was he in comms or was he exactly,
he was head,
he was a head of our corporate communications
and did just a phenomenal job.
And so we have great fun working on this podcast.
Uh,
and then the,
uh,
when I started retirement,
I had this elegant theory or I thought it was elegant.
I said I got to spend a third of my time on business stuff,
third of my time on personal stuff and that third of my time giving back.
And that actually is turns out to be sort of a useless way to think about it.
Why is that?
Well,
um,
it's sort of choppy and it's not continuous enough.
And um,
it struck me recently,
so in November I got to spend a day,
this is an interesting story in itself.
I got to spend a day traveling around with Ken Langone,
who,
Ken is one of the Co founders of Home Depot.
He was my lead director at the start of Home Depot.
And he's just one of the life's phenomenal people.
And I realized at the end of it that really what I want to learn is I,
I,
I want to figure out how to be authentically generous and whatever it is I'm
doing.
I mean,
some people pay me for help.
Some people don't pay me for help.
People who pay me for,
I'll probably frustrated
by it,
but,
uh,
it's generosity.
How do I,
so putting that piece together with Welch's final advice and how did you learn
to do that?
And it doesn't,
it's not something that comes naturally to me.
Uh,
I'm not the kind of person who,
you know,
you see the beggar on the street and I reached in my pocket and give a buck.
I'm much more of the kind of person who's going,
oh,
that's not really going to help him for the following reason.
Um,
but that's my,
so that's what I'm working on.
I'm trying to figure out how to be more genuinely helpful and generous.
How are you working on it?
So,
because it seems like,
just like with worry,
you have subsets of worry,
there are many different ways to be generous and it,
it might mean different things to different people.
Yeah,
exactly.
So how are you working on,
yeah,
so,
and I don't,
and I'm way short,
right way,
way,
way short of,
but I know if you kind of work right to left and you go,
what do I want people to say?
I'd love them to say that at,
you know,
whenever,
uh,
so,
so there are small things,
um,
in terms of,
uh,
just giving money,
giving money is one way to do it.
I'm trying to be helpful when you do it so that it's not just writing a check
and it actually takes a lot of thought.
I've learned this,
you know,
I get to hang around a fair amount with Ken and with Bernie and Bernie.
Now what he does is his foundation.
That's what Ken does.
I you think about doing that and how you actually think about being helpful to
people as you're generous with your own resources.
Um,
it's learning and I can tell there are some things I do where I think I'm being
helpful where people go,
God,
that's fascinating,
but keep your help
do yourself.
And other things I do where,
where I think I'm,
I'm a little more successful on where,
where do you think,
what falls in the latter category of,
uh,
particularly people who are starting things,
um,
and uh,
for whatever reason in dealing with their own anxiety,
uh,
find it helpful to talk to somebody else who's got some perspective and can help
them feel like they're making progress on whatever direction they're they're
going.
Um,
and I think one of the great things that's true now that wasn't true,
you know,
when I was throwing up,
is that people are actually really willing to take some risks and do things and
start their own businesses and start their own charities and step out.
And that's phenomenal.
And helping.
That is great.
So there,
there are probably hundreds of thousands,
maybe millions of entrepreneurs listening to this.
And I'd love to go to some of my,
my well-worn rapid fire questions,
but I might tweak it a little bit.
So I very often ask about the most gifted books or most re-read,
which I'll probably ask anyway,
but we're going to back into that by asking,
uh,
if are there any particular books you would recommend,
if you could recommend to say two or three books could be more to an
entrepreneur,
maybe they're a year into their business or in the early stages.
Uh,
doesn't necessarily have to be early stages.
I'm,
I know I'm adding a lot of qualifiers here,
but what books might you recommend to them?
Uh,
so we talked about one of them built from scratch I think is,
uh,
is just a great book.
And any entrepreneur should read it saying this,
not because I'm on this podcast,
but because I started listening to your podcasts and I think your books are
phenomenal.
And I think,
uh,
what's great about them is,
that,
that you make an effort to kind of pull out from people.
Here's what I think is,
you know,
kind of a core part of what makes whatever it is I do successful.
And as a reader or as a listener,
I can kind of choose.
I could say,
yeah,
okay,
that makes sense.
Or No,
boy,
that person's just wait,
wait,
doing something different.
And I don't believe,
uh,
I don't believe that there's any one particular,
you know,
I as a business person,
I love Jim Collins is good,
you know,
good,
great.
But you can also look at that and go,
oh,
this is fascinating because the companies that were originally in good to grade
are now not so great,
not even existing.
So,
uh,
so you have to be willing to understand that there are lots of different stories
and then you find your own within that.
Um,
so I,
so I give your book because I think it's,
I think it's very cool.
I think it's,
I think it's much more,
uh,
people have to have more respect for differences and different ways of
approaching problems is no one path,
no one path.
Are there any books besides built a from scratch that you've gifted a lot to
other people or re-read a lot yourself?
So the book I tend to gift people is not,
has nothing to do with uh,
um,
business.
It's a book by a writer called Clive James and it's called Cultural Amnesia.
And,
uh,
first off he writes a w he is so learned that,
you just want to read what he has to say.
So He's,
and I assume he's not making this up,
but you know,
he says,
well,
you know,
I wanted to read Proust,
but I didn't know French.
So I started with the La Rousse and start learning French.
And you go,
okay,
anybody who do that,
I'm
interested in what he has to say.
But the book is interesting because it talks about,
uh,
to me it's interesting because it talks about how World War Two and the guilt
around World War II,
particularly in Europe infected the,
all of the sort of liberal arts world and the unwillingness to actually face
into,
uh,
the fact that there was more collaboration than people wanted to admit.
And so oftentimes the people that were truly heroic,
our actual are actually,
uh,
heavily criticized because the people who are less than heroic couldn't stand
the comparisons.
And you go through all of these different literary figures and you go,
Whoa,
didn't know that backstory.
That's pretty interesting.
So it's cultural amnesia.
Is it a collection of examples in narratives related to,
I'm just trying to make sure I'm clear.
Different different authors and these are people who are chopped down by their
contemporaries because of their success.
Yeah.
Huh.
[inaudible] or venerated now,
but no one really sees through to,
hey,
maybe,
maybe there's,
they're more feet of clay and then want to say,
it makes me think of,
uh,
that sounds fantastic.
I want to check that out because,
and then do you give that to people?
Well,
let me spit out what it was on top of my brain,
which was,
it reminds me of a quote from Francis Ford Coppola when he was being interviewed
by a friend of mine,
Robert Rodriguez,
who's here in Austin filmmaker.
And I think it was during this interview that he said,
I'm paraphrasing,
but of course Francis Ford Coppola,
one of the greats.
And he said the same things that get you fired when you're younger.
The things that give you lifetime achievement award,
which I thought was great.
A keen observation.
Uh,
do you give this to,
do you give this to people to embolden them,
to give them courage to do things with the expectation of facing that type of
blow back or why do you give this book?
I,
I give it first because,
uh,
when he talks,
so the Cultural Amnesia is the subtext of what he's talking about.
But he also just is such a great observer of different writers and,
uh,
it makes you want to read all of the source material that he's writing about.
So if you like reading books and I like reading books,
it's one of those books that first,
as I say,
you go,
this may be the smartest human being who's ever put pen to paper and,
um,
just brilliantly smart.
And secondly,
that's an interesting
way to look at history and how history has impacted things,
but it's more just do you love books and you love these,
these authors.
Are there any books that you've finished recently or that you're reading
currently?
So the book that I just finished recently,
I heart,
it's not a full fledged book,
so it's real short 300 arguments by Sarah Manguso.
Hmm.
Um,
and it's,
it's,
it's kind of a neat book because her objective is,
I'm going to reduce this book to the 300 things that you'd underline if I wrote
a real.
So it's got a lot of little,
it's,
it's uh,
I mean you can read it in less than an hour,
uh,
but it's got a really,
it's,
it's kind of like Montanian it's like,
um,
little statement,
lots of Aphorisms,
little aphorism.
What's the theme of the book or,
great question.
And if I were a deeper reader,
I'd probably be able to tell you the theme and I'm,
I'm probably doing her book massive injustice by not knowing what the theme is.
To me it was sort of a random collectic mix.
I mean,
it just bounces,
bounces around with different observations,
some of which you go,
God,
that's brilliant.
And some of them,
ah,
but how do you,
how did you choose that book?
And I guess the broader question is how do you choose books?
Because we all have finite time on this planet.
Yeah.
How did,
how do you go about choosing books?
So on that one,
uh,
and I can't remember how,
what the Path was,
the gut meet this guy who writes a blog,
Austin Cleon and
also an Austinite.
He's also here.
Oh,
no kidding.
All right.
So I don't know quite why I got steal.
Like an artist I think is one of his books.
He's a number.
So I,
so I start reading his blog and he talks about,
and he had something that said,
here are the 15 best books I read in 2017 and I go done.
I've got to read the 15.
And that was one of the books yet some others.
And I'm going through,
I'm going to make this all 15.
Hello Austin.
Good work,
sir.
Uh,
this,
the next question is very much a left turn.
Uh,
and it's,
it's a hit or miss question.
So if it's,
if it's a flub on my side,
we can,
we can skip it.
But what is the purchase of $100 or less?
It could be $1,000 or less,
whatever that comes to mind that has positively impacted your life in the last
year or two.
Does anything come to mind?
So if I can bump it up above $200.
Sure.
It's shoes.
All right.
So,
so recognize that I spent years walking concrete floors and you know what,
as I was saying on my back thing,
you know,
shoes are just hugely important.
So I got a shoe that I actually really like what's up?
What does the,
so does the same hopper choose Sam Hubbard?
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
so to me finding it,
yeah.
So all my,
all for the [inaudible]
last however many years,
I don't have the patience to actually get,
you know,
go through the right sizing.
And so I never wear the right size and,
uh,
it's just been an enormous frustration.
And I finally found a pair of shoes.
I really liked Sam Hubbard.
Yeah.
I big fan of shoes.
Well,
I,
I became fixated on shoes at one point because,
uh,
as backstory I'd been extremely stingy.
Stingy sounds too scrooge McDuck cheap economical,
uh,
for my entire life really.
I mean,
I was the guy who would have his,
his girlfriend complained about the single ply toilet paper and be like,
really,
really tell him like,
can we just get to apply?
This is terrible.
It's great.
And,
uh,
I would always buy the cheapest shoes that seemed comfortable and were tolerable
to my girlfriend a aesthetically.
And at one point I was in Panama talking to this wonderful woman woman who was
the wife of,
uh,
this gent who at one point had owned the largest brewery in Panama,
maybe Central America and a really wise woman.
And she said to me,
you know,
Tim,
cause she was looking at my shoes and had nothing appropriate for Panama.
And she said,
there are two places you should really spend money.
She said if necessary,
your mattress and your shoes because if you're not in one,
you're going to be was like
phenomenal advice.
So the same Humbard I mean I,
I really pay attention to the shoes now because uh,
well I should say what contributed to that or reinforced it was my experience in
writing about cooking.
And you have line cooks or standing all day mall prep.
I mean they're standing all day and they,
a lot of them wear shoes designed for hospital use for their,
these slip on shoes that are used by nurses and doctors.
Fantastic.
All right,
well I have,
I have a shoe type to check out.
Uh,
if you were to teach a class to,
let's call it high school seniors or college students,
you could,
you could pick the grade and actually you could pick any grade.
What class would you teach and why?
Uh,
history,
just because history is about people.
Uh,
history,
we learned so much from history.
I'd love teaching history.
Well I wasn't a great history student,
but after,
you know,
when you think about what books are fun to read,
it's great to read history books.
And so any particular focus,
what would the course description look like?
Uh,
I like American history.
I'm not that familiar with,
you know,
I haven't spent enough time to know the history of other countries,
but I think our history is,
is unbelievably complex and fascinating.
Cause
I been going through the Oxford history of the United States soar book by book.
Um,
and they get maybe more deeply and then I might want to,
but it's fascinating.
It's great.
Is there any particular historical figure from us history and that was a little
department of redundancy department,
but that's okay.
Is there any historical figure in the u s you would particularly have liked to
meet
or have dinner with his?
Anyone?
Anyone come to mind?
Aye.
Um,
for there,
so there's so many,
right.
You could list more than you could.
You could,
you could,
uh,
have a lot of,
a lot of fascinating,
a lot of fascinating people.
I'd actually,
Truman is of Truman would be interesting in Eisenhower would be interesting.
I think both of those characters,
uh,
you know,
for the decisions they faced.
And obviously Eisenhower,
uh,
you know,
I think we,
so he was the president that I grew up with and so much deeper than any picture
that we have of him that would be interesting.
Eisenhower gets used a lot as an example by Peter Drucker is an executive as an
effective,
I believe that the military has so much,
I've had,
has so many great learnings on
Bader Shit,
a lot to be borrowed low,
a lot to be barbed there for sure.
All right.
Last last few questions.
If you could put anything on a billboard,
metaphorically speaking,
so a word,
a sentence,
a quote could be yours or someone else's to get out to millions or billions of
people.
What might you put on that?
Uh,
the,
it would be,
uh,
the only blessings you own or the ones you share.
And,
um,
that's,
you know,
that's the most fun thing about this crazy good turns thing is seeing the people
who live that every day who are seeing things.
I'm seeing plights people in need that others,
I mean,
there's a great one.
I could go on and on about this,
but there's a great story on who knew that there were homeless people living in
tunnels under Los Vegas.
And then here's a guy who recognizes this and goes and takes care of the
homeless people in Tunnels and Las Vegas and you go,
wow,
that's amazing.
Got To more of that,
please.
Um,
so
that's crazy good turns.
Yeah.
If you want it to get someone hooked on crazy good turns.
Are there one or two episodes that you might,
they
start with?
Uh,
I've,
I would start at the start.
Um,
so the team Rubicon,
we did early one on team Rubicon,
which is the group of Iraqi and Afghan war veterans who come back and,
you know,
people are probably familiar with them.
They use their military training to go,
you know,
if there's a flood,
they go and address the flood and amazing,
it's an amazing,
uh,
group,
early on.
I mean,
they're all,
I love,
uh,
you know,
it's like kits,
which,
which your favorite kits.
I just,
so that's the first one,
but every single one of them.
And then I think the second one we did was,
uh,
um,
about tunnel to towers,
tunnels to tower.
You know,
the story of the guy who was the fireman on his day off.
And,
uh,
the twin towers are hit and he's driving in to help his,
a fire,
you know,
his colleagues.
And the tunnel is by backed up.
And so he puts all his gear and runs through the tunnel to the towers and
unfortunately died.
And then there's now a,
um,
uh,
a run every year through the tower and commemoration of that.
But you know,
just people are,
so I,
I'd start with the start and the first ones,
but I love the mall there.
As I say,
it's like choosing among kids.
Why did you create it or why did you create it?
What's,
why put us into the world?
I mean,
I know it takes effort.
It,
uh,
it's the,
so if,
if,
um,
when we started it was,
uh,
my first comment to Bradshaw,
the guy who does it with me was I,
if eight people listen to this,
I'll be thrilled because I just want to take someone who's done amazing things
and talk about them and just have them have a notion that someone's going to
spend,
you know,
ours are short,
the 25 minutes,
25 minutes talking about the great thing they do.
And then Brad did such a good job of it.
But now we're saying,
okay,
we want people to listen to it.
But it's,
it's,
um,
it goes back to the concept of celebrating whatever it is you want.
Celebrate,
highlight and highlight it and tell stories about it.
And,
uh,
we connect from hearing these stories and sometimes you go,
wow,
this person's just so much better person than I'm ever going to be that forget
it.
That's how the Ballpark,
but it's still inspirational.
And then some of them you go,
Oh yeah,
okay.
I can,
I can do that.
Maybe I'll correct course one day.
Yeah.
So for all of you complain that my interviews are too long,
uh,
I mean certainly many of you listen to the entire interview,
but if you'd like a short form fix,
you just check out crazy good turns.
And I'm going to make,
I don't do this very much,
but I'm going to make an ask of the audience and then I'm going to ask you if
you have any parting words,
advice or asks of the audience.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
beyond checking out crazy good turns.
I would challenge everyone listening for a day,
maybe a week to not criticize,
so to,
to try to put into practice what we've been talking about and that is
highlighting and applauding what it is you want to see more of in the world.
If you,
if you see someone online who is doing something great,
who's making sacrifices for the,
for the greater good
practice applauding that because if you do criticize and the criticism online is
certainly 99% of what we see,
but you practice makes perfect even if the practice isn't a good practice.
So if you've,
if you focus on being critical,
you'll get better at it and it will become easier.
So for day,
for a week,
try to focus on applauding what it is you want to see more of out in the world.
So that'd be my,
my challenge,
my suggestion to everybody who is listening to this.
And I will do the same for myself.
I will eat my own dog food on that one.
Uh,
so,
uh,
any,
any parting words?
Well,
that's the questions.
I'm not going to begin to improve on that.
Brilliant.
And it is so true.
It's so true.
If you take time to recognize and appreciate other people,
uh,
it bounces back.
It gives back and very cool.
Perfect.
Well,
sorry to go first.
No,
but I want it to get that.
I feel so strongly about it.
There's so much negativity out of the world,
out in the world,
you and I,
none of us have to create more of it.
There's a surplus of negativity.
So try to focus on increasing the positivity and,
uh,
you don't get the positive just by shutting down the negative.
That void doesn't fill itself.
Uh,
where can people learn more about you,
find you online if,
if,
if there is any way that you would like to share.
And of course,
everyone who is listening to this,
you can find the show notes with links to everything,
including crazy good turns and so on at Tim.
Dot.
Blog forward slash,
podcast.
But is there a,
are there any other places people can say,
say hello or learn more about what you're up to?
Uh,
at Frank Bike on Twitter?
Um,
uh,
that's,
that's how it blends the dominant in addition to the crazy good turns.
Fantastic.
Well,
frank,
thank you so much for your time.
Thank you.
This was a lot of fun and,
uh,
for everyone out there on the interwebs,
wherever you may be,
as always,
thank you for listening.
Talk to you next time.